that many words to say i mean the only
thing i might mention i couldn't resist
having seen david quote these papers was
that you know
david saw the link i didn't necessarily
but
i
it gives me more of an incentive now to
look very carefully at the papers to the
extent i
i may be able to understand them anyway
um i and also i would like to take the
opportunity
of uh
well i don't know about dancing i mean
that david is himself a
an avid dancer
but um
the the tribute that he paid
to nancy which
well obviously i share
and i'm i'm very grateful to see that
um
so so um
yes it's very difficult to say something
after this lecture but but i i would
like to thank
everybody
all the speakers who are still here
and
the the organizers
particularly or not particularly but
including absolutely the
chairs the co-chairs
of the of the uh
organizing committee um
it's been a wonderful experience
actually and uh
i keep on i
recently was at a
similar thing for brad efron and i just
remember that
one remark of his which i always
paraphrase incorrectly i think but
that it's nice to be have nice things
said about you
so
so i i appreciate it too and i i thank
everybody but there's been a lot of
effort put into this
and uh a lot of effort in people coming
to
to this
um
i
i'm not
uh
not nearly as convinced of
my position as david
uh
puts it but
uh anyway i i i'm
again i'm very grateful and
thank you all
[Applause]
okay so now it's the time to uh wrap up
so uh we we have uh six poster awards to
present but before that so just in case
i forget so there are two announcements
i would like to make so the first
announcement is that so there will be a
uc berkeley statistics department i knew
a illuminae reunion at the gsm
so it's scheduled on tuesday august 9th
at 6 30 p.m
so if you are planning to go to gsm so
please drop by
so that'll be a great time for all of us
to get together again and another
announcement is that so we are preparing
a photo book as a gift to peter and
nancy so if you have taken some nice
photos you know during the program so
please send us photos to leader me or
okay katarina so we will put the photo
book together
so that's another thing
so now is the time to present the postal
world so some for the students
you know for the post session so we have
seen a lot of excellent you know posters
and the quality high quality of the work
so we want to award our students for
their
efforts and the talents
so we have uh six postal awards and the
first award committee
so pong will present that so i will
announce the names so let me find out
the names first
okay
so the first one is
from
so the title is the population level
violence in sonic networks
congratulations
[Applause]
so the next one is yulin yen
who is a pc student in the department of
operation research
and the financial engineering at the
princeton
high tide influence for
cathode scale basic pca with missing
data
so next one is uh julio lin
the title is estimation based on nearest
the neighbor matching from density ratio
to average treatment effect
so a second year master's student in the
department of statistics at the
university congratulations
[Applause]
and actually
joshua is joining uc berkeley study
department as a pg student this fall
so look forward to see you again soon
yeah
the next one is uh
tabaya
mu mukiji
so the title is a regression
discriminative design
estimating the treatment effect with
standard parametric rate
so he is a fourth year graduate student
in the department of statistics at the
university of michigan congratulations
[Applause]
so next one is robot
lund
so the title is a conformer
prediction for network-assisted
regression uh researcher file a research
file in the department statistics at the
university of michigan
the next one the last one is alina
lina
is she here as she
she's oh yeah
she's a
pg student in the department statistic
at stanford congratulations so all of
our winners are there
okay so now it's really the time to uh
wrap up
so i want to thank simon's institute
again and also peter butler so he
another peterby for
for the generous support for this whole
program and we have amazing staff
members like that the the person who
helped all of the presentations and also
the person have a prepared food so we
really appreciate you know the generous
support from the the samus institute and
all of the staff members
and also i want to thank
all of our organizers again
like lisa and also her amazing assistant
anna so even though anna you know wasn't
able to make this meeting but she has
done a lot and i guess a lot of you have
received emails you know from her about
a lot of the details of the program and
the other organizers like funding unlike
uh jane tim and peter and also uh
catharina and myself and also the state
department at uc berkeley so we also got
staff support from the uc berkeley uh
study department especially for the
financial thing so a lot of our junior
faculty and
our postdoc students will be uh
receiving funding support from this
program and actually so the staff
members and study department at uc
berkeley will have processed that
so we have a big team you know
supporting this whole thing and so so i
want to thank you know the whole team
again for for for making this one
successful
so that's the following what peter has
said i want to thank everyone for the
participation of this program for all of
the excellent talks so it has been three
days but i just feel that like this can
can really last forever i really enjoyed
all of the the talks i have heard so
with all of you here so that is making
this is so successful thank you all you
know for attending this program thank
you
finally i want to thank peter and nancy
for letting us do this so give us this
great opportunity you know to put this
together and to have everyone here you
know to just celebrate you know peter
and
hopefully
yeah for everything thank you okay thank
you everyone
[Applause]